now to shed some light on everyone's
assumptions about the genetic basis for
male behavior in other words guys like
to show off we just can't help ourselves
this group of chimpanzees is exhibiting
behavior scientifically known as display
this means that males are playing mr.
big stock will show the other males who
is the top chip now these chimps are
unable to wear flashy suits by a
football team or drive a high-end
convertible to show females what they're
all about instead they're reduced or
maybe we should say elevated to this
kind of display if you were a female
channel you would presumably be going
wild right now